hi i'm shruti hirahara i'm going to talk
about italics versus era from africa's
compressed this is a joint work with
rafale sansana
in the theory of averages complexity we
study a distributional problem
which is a pair of decision problem l
under the family of distributions d
over instances of l
in the averages complexity we ask the
following question
is the decision problem error easy on
average with respect to the distribution
d
more specifically let's say you were
given a random input x which is drawn
from the distribution d
can we decide whether x is in the
language l or not with high probability
efficiently
um when we try to formalize
this question there are at least two
ways to formalize averages tractability
errors or error-prone heuristics
it is often denoted by
average p
errors is derived by average p and the
error prone polynomial time algorithm is
denoted by hulu p
in this work we initiate the study of
the relationship between heroes and
era from averages compressed this
let me explain the motivation to study
this question
there is a very influential paper about
abilities compressive written by
impagratsu
he proposed five possible powers that
are consistent with our current
knowledge on cryptography and
comprehensive theory
for example peaceland is the worst
possible world
if its np is held on average but there
is no one-way function
similarly heuristical is a world where
there are efficient heuristics when p in
the sense that np is easy on average but
np is hard in the worst case
now in order to formalize these two
words
we need to decide which notion we should
use iris or error prone
therefore it's not quite natural to ask
whether these two notions are equivalent
to each other
in fact this question was
explicitly raised by impacts of the
original paper
he raised the question whether
distribution of np is in qrp in price
distribution b is in average p
here qrp is a cross of distribution
problem that can be solved by error
press error-prone polynomial averages
algorithms
more specifically we say that l common d
is in qrp if there is a polynomial time
algorithm a such that
the following force
a takes
some parameter k which specifies the
error probability of the algorithm
and if we pick x from the
distribution distribution d
the property that a fails to compute the
correct answer l of x is at most one
over k
this is the notion of q
repeat
in contrast to this average b which is a
class of
distribution problems that can be solved
by rarest averages per unit time
we additionally require
the algorithm
output either the correctness or error
of x or a specialist bottom symbol which
indicates that the algorithm doesn't
know the answer
so obviously this is a stronger notion
than surely p
the question in pagodas asked is that
whether these are equivalent for np or
not
before explaining our result
let me explain the key in her side or
the starting point of this paper
our main starting point is that we find
a connection between instant checker and
the question of the infographic
namely if we have a non-adductive
instant checker for an np-complete
problem we can show that the answer to
the importance of this question is
positive
more generally we can show that the
existence of an instant checker
gives
a reduction from error
less to error-prone averages compressed
this for example
if you are not familiar with instant
checkup
one canonical way to construct
um
in stata is to consider an interactive
proof system for example if we have a ph
um if we can show that ph limits uh
interactive proof system with a ph
honest approval
is a bit essentially equivalent to
having instant checkup for ph
in that case we can show that the
averages compressed it are prone
averages compressive ph and hilarious
averages compressive ph are equivalent
to each other
currently what we know about the
interactive proof system for ph is that
ph admits um interactive proof system
with p to g sharp p computable honest
approval
so if we can improve this
complexity of honest approval we might
we can
prove the equivalence
between two different notions of obvious
complexity for
ph now let me introduce those three our
main result
the first result shows that we can get
equivalence in a certain setting
if we consider
averages bursting over instant checker
in a non-uniform setting we can actually
get an exact equivalence
specifically we can show that the
following
equivalent
there is an errors to allow prone
reduction showing that errors
compressive energy and error prone
compressed of np or equipment
if and only if there is a non-adaptive
average vpp search poly instead poorly
instantiated criticism avalanches person
and winston checker for
np complete problem
one way to interpret this result is that
this provides a new approach for
errors to era prone reduction
actually it is a long-standing open
question to construct
whilst case instant checker for an nlp
computer problem which is actually
expressed raised in the seminal work of
brahma and the current
but in order to construct um arrivals to
error-prone reduction we showed that
average test
instant checkpoint is sufficient
so this provides a approach towards
relatives to aeroplane reduction
moreover we can show that there is a
huge bpp instant checker which is a
weaker notion than average bpp instant
checker but we can construct such an
instant checker for and be complete
problems unconditionally
the second result is some unconditional
result about the equivalence between two
averages compressed this
we were able to show the equivalence
between errors and error prone ambiguous
compresses for p and u b in the sect
call up
for example in the case of p we can show
that error less complexity and error
from averages compresses are equivalent
for example in the case of nc1 we can
state it in this way
the proof idea is basically quite simple
the reason we can get certain
equivalence is that there is an instant
checker for p computable problems by
using the connection from instant
checker to erupt rest process airplane
averages compresses we can get this
equivalence
similarly for up intersect coil up
we can show a similar result showing
that errors and error-prone averages
compresses are equivalent for ub
industries call up
our final result shows
concerns the difference between
polynomial
pseudonym generator and polynomial
computer hitting central generator
in general these two notions are not
known to be
equivalent if we consider polynomial
time computable
generate our prg's
but
if we
consider a serial extending version
we are able to show the equivalence
between these two notions
here we say that this is c extending if
the function g
takes ac
z
and it outputs z at the prefix of the
output
now we can prove the following
equivalence
the first statement says that there is a
polynomial computable zero extending
hitting set to the entire with c lengths
n minus one which is secure against u1
in general
it's not even if you have a heating set
generator with c links n minus 1 it's
not known whether you can reduce the
seedlings in general but in the case of
zero extending heating center generator
we were able to show that we can reduce
the seed lengths to energy epsilon for
every constant efficiency
the proof
is based on the equivalence between
heating saturated
and
pseudonymous generator
let me explain the key idea of our paper
namely i'm going to explain the
connection from the insulin checker to
errors process airplane averages
compresses
in order to explain this let me first
recall the notion of instant check
an oracle machine c is called an instant
checker for language l if we have the
following two properties the first
condition which is completeness says the
following
if you are given the correct
correct oracle l
that instant checker the probability
that the instant checker output or
longer answer is at most a quarter
this is completeness
the soundness states that for every
oracle a
the instant checker
the probability that the intent taker
out of its
wrong
answer is a atmosphere quote
here the instructor is allowed to output
the special bottom symbol which is
indicates the failure of the computation
so in some sense this is an error this
this is quite similar to the definition
of errors averages complexities so i'm
what i'm going to show you is that by
using this intent checker we can convert
here bpp algorithm for l comma d prime
for some distribution d prime can be
converted into errors averages
polynomial algorithm for l comma d
so so in order to prove this let cube is
a query distribution of the non-adaptive
instant checker c
now we can define d prime to be
q
composed with d
and then we take uh error from heuristic
a for the distribution problem l comma d
prime
now we can describe
errors averages algorithm for error
comma d
which we call b
so the definition of the errors
heuristic b is as follows
input x
you simulate the checker
on input x
and if the taker makes a query
then we answer it by using the errors
error prong heuristic a
here we take a sufficient rise parameter
t so that the error prone heuristic
schemes uh
correct with high probability
now i'm going to show explain why this
is a errors heuristic briefly
the reason why b is correct with high
probability follows from the
completeness of its instant check
by using a union bond we can guarantee
that the profit the probability that all
the queries that are
produced by
the checker can be answered correctly by
using the error from heuristic a
so that's why b is correct with a high
probability
similarly
we can prove the sound we can prove that
b is errors by using this soundness
condition
so this is why we can get the reduction
from iras complexity to error-prone
averages compressed
by using instant checker
to conclude this talk we have identified
the connection between iras process era
from averages compresses and instant
checkers
there are a lot of interesting open
questions about this paper
one important open question is whether
we can consult on average bpp search
party instant checker for np complete
problems
if we can do that we can construct it
rights to error-prone
reductions
alternatively we can try to give a
negative evidence against this
um
what's most related to this question is
the work by bogdanon hunter represent
who showed that there is no non-adaptive
waste yesterday averages reduction and
ph core processes
our notion of errors to error problem
reduction is a weaker notion so if we
can extend their result to our setting
we can give a negative answer to the
main question
thank you for
listening